good to be here everybody responds can
and I know what it looked like but I'm
not that into anime okay which is
unfortunate because only women were
sexually interested in me all seven of
them they're pretty into anime it's like
the whole thing I forgot an interesting
anime face constantly cosplay it's just
my Nana Asian boys I used to date a
woman who is really into yoga and choke
sex I was like do you enjoy breathing or
not Millennials like me old people
complain about our social skills but
only think they do it theirs is complain
about the progress we're making oh you
said yeah it's pretty cool you know I
don't understand these people they're
like back in my day we used to be able
to look each other in the eye and
convince each other to commit genocide
kids these days don't even know how to
start a mob anymore come on to me put on
your bow to choose her right there all
the words genocides happened before the
internet so take some responsibility
pretty the human eye to eye
communication is the best why that's how
all the genocides start is with someone
saying I like the way your eyes look
comes together see it's like it is not
to be funny it's just word association I
I think capitalism is fine if you want
to do it just don't make everyone play
your stupid game
I like fortnight I don't make a grandma
play and take away
House assurances I am a proud supporter
of Andrew yang or I was I guess we're
not in yanqing anymore we're disbanded
we'll never get to live in a gangster's
paradise it's gonna be a gangbanger bang
bang bang I believe in universal basic
income I think if everyone got $1,000
every month you guys would be a lot more
bearable to be around here's some money
some playing music on the bus it's a
public utility I paid for it there's
something culture that's just what
people do when they're hungry
I just think poor people are disgusting
and we should get rid of every single
one if I give them a lot of money I
think it's funny that Americans will say
communism never works as if we didn't
spend billions of dollars and chameleons
and people to make sure what it works
[Laughter]
Vietnam we're pretty anxious about it
not war negated we're giving it a
hundred and ten percent companies it
never works because whatever people
control the means of production they're
democratically like the leaders
mysteriously died and the small rebel
group always finds automatic weapons way
to say buzzing so many so
I'm not a communist but I do support any
policies that Republicans consider
communism which is whatever two or more
people gather to do something nice I
just don't think that the best way to
judge policies is what superpower would
have supported it in the fifties yeah
how about we just judge it whether it's
gonna know we're like what did you say
the Russians are all most important
their people will show that we'll do the
opposite will not take care of our
people that's the American Way because
it's the opposite of what they're doing
I mean let's give it a shot okay [ __ ]
well I didn't even do in here I think
it's weird that tanner is a white
person's name and then what is my
Mexican friend Tanner Janice it's hard
to be Asian you know a lot of people
make fun of us for unique dogs which I
understand to be very shocking because
in America dr. tree like family members
but in Asia we treat our family members
like family members the tradition we
have back home
instead of buying an animal we love our
grandma in Asia unless the baby girl
which is you throw them in the river
better I like to eat General Tso's
chicken and my friends like dude isn't
that just a shitty Americanized version
of something on technically Asian and
I'm like yeah but some of mine is rush
hour 3 I am NOT a racist I don't even
see race and we smell it
polish in here at an airport and I saw
dude reading a book in Arabic which kind
of freaked me out but then it's unfolded
corner of the page I put the book away
and I was like oh thank god a future
plans
our literature loved race you know I
don't like how Asian women I think
there's such on a [ __ ] in America but in
fact comb or throw you guys away so
impress me I could throw on a wig it'd
be a seven do you look like me under
president anyone could [ __ ] white dudes
I can [ __ ] white is that you still want
to women the Heidi thing that created me
[ __ ] okay crucial part of the sexy
process please stop trying to scare me
if you have sex with me our children oh
you're very beautiful half of them will
be great engineers in that support tuna
I am a sapiosexual so I'm looking for a
girlfriend who is intellectually
stimulated by the mental exercise have
find me attractive
I listen to puzzles tonight okay I could
begin us out let's go I Creek women out
a lot in public because they're very
beautiful physically and I stare at them
but it's not my fault because to me a
woman is like a beautiful scenic sunset
that can yell at ego
got a balance idea they can call the
cops I got a beach with the pepper spray
you can't take a picture even late a lot
too sexy all right
[Applause]